George Michael Friday here at Verizon
stop welcome to our number three of the
Rich Eisen show that is the the Ohio
State fight song played for a man as if
there's not enough Ohio State on his
chest and on his hat he's got an Ohio
State hat on he's got an Ohio State
sweatshirt on and he's got a great movie
father figures coming out on December
22nd and then coming up in January a
star series called counterpart where he
plays not one but two people well still
I guess the same person but I don't
write two different characters JK
Simmons plays it's good to see you sir I
would normally say better for seeing you
but I'm looking at you and I got how are
you now I'm good I'm good yeah you could
cover it up as much as you want to
boxers on to the box well what did you
think of the the Ohio State finish and
the fact that they were left out of the
the quartet JK you know well
disappointed but honestly you know if we
just showed up against Iowa there
wouldn't have been a debate so you know
I mean you leave it up to the committee
the committee makes the choice they make
and last year maybe we didn't really
deserve to be there so you know I mean
it's it's hard to complain and I'm
really really excited about the Cotton
Bowl yeah I mean I mean that's gonna be
a great game it is in a lot you know a
lot of people even looking at running
back the national championship for a
third time in a national semifinal
between Alabama and Clemson and
obviously Georgia and Oklahoma playing
out here in the Rose Bowl having a de
facto Rose Bowl set up in Texas a lot of
people think that that might be the game
the bull game of the year yeah I think
it could be yeah you know so and then
watching watching this team and J&J T
Barrett I mean what what you know
watching watching him go down and still
you winning the big game what did that
mean to you Jay Casey by the big game
which was stopped now you stop now stop
now it's all cyclical you know it's
cyclical
you know it's sick yes so but I have to
in listen I live through John Cooper you
know right and and that's going in as a
favorite every year and you guys
spanking us and
you know I mean it was so again I know I
asked you this question every time but I
have to JK Simmons Academy award-winner
here on the Rich Eisen show how does one
be a tiger fan and an Ohio State fan
it's it's just pure geography I was born
in mmm here in the Old English D in town
my dad was a public school teacher there
and then when I was 10 years old he got
a job as a college teacher at the Ohio
State University and and I mean I'm not
gonna stop rooting for the Tigers sure
and I moved to Cola I'm not gonna work
for the Columbus Clippers they were no
certainly if you're a triple-a team of
the Yankees think there were the Yankees
yeah there at the time then yeah so yeah
all my new pals there were either Reds
fans or Indians fans and and I clung to
my Tiger fandom and shortly after was
rewarded in 1968 when I was 13 and had
what I used to call the greatest World
Series of all time but it's a little
tough after the after the Cubs Indian
series out of which and in this year's -
I mean this yes - what was it like
watching Verlander win it it was that
was a head there was a head Bob a side
right there it was painful
it was and I mean I when when the trade
happened you know one second before
midnight on the I I was really in shock
I mean I felt like you know my
girlfriend had broken up with me or
something and and I thought well I can't
root for him somewhere else I mean I I
mean I've you know I know him we've hung
out a little bit he's a great guy but I
said I can't how can I root for him
wearing you know the Lone Star on his
hat but then I you know the first time I
watched I was like go JV hey well
certainly when he was doing against the
Yankees I'm sure that well that versed
to Newark that helped too because that
was that was awesome obviously you know
you know I'm a New York or any Yankee
fan but just watching Verlander in this
day and age of where pitchers leave
after five and a third because
manager has the numbers about third time
through the order right letter D against
righty especially in the postseason they
leave after two of the third right and
that we saw that for the Dodgers
actually I think in Game two against the
Astros just seeing somebody saying here
it is hit it in the ninth inning I I
mean you just don't see that much no it
was like it was like Segway Segway yes a
Jack Morris it was it really was like a
Jack Morris performance refreshing to
see someone who's all said and done you
were happy for Verlander it's what
you're saying yes yes reluctantly happy
there's gonna there's a lot of X Tigers
I can be happy for the next few years
cuz it's been you know I mean I'll be
rooting for the mud ends in will be
playing in Detroit well you know Justin
Upton and Ian Kinsler are playing out
here the Mud Hens are technically the
old the the team of the childhood team
of both Harbaugh and Urban Meyer correct
weren't they born in the same hospital
well yeah I believe that's right there
on the border of that stayed up north is
you would like to say where apparently
there's a there's a new highway sign
there on Route 23 as you're crossing
into Michigan that says you know one of
the green signs with the white lettering
this is welcome to Michigan property of
Urban Meyer's it does not say that they
used to say property of Jim Tressel they
just because and what do you think of
Mars finally getting through to a more
troopers 10 you know I richly deserve
both of I mean he and Trammell and and
and trammels a guy that because he was
just so steady and and and you know the
Wizard of Oz of course is you know his
deservedly obviously a Hall of Famer but
you know you put trammels numbers up
against his even defensively he wasn't
flashy but he was so so steady I mean
both those guys it's it's richly
deserved yeah I mean don't you think
though Trammell certainly with his glove
Whitaker should
- just because of that um right there
well no no such thing as a man with an
Ohio State hat and sweatshirt on right
now almost were the Tigers cap - I know
but honestly when I JK Simmons here in
the Rich Eisen show I saw you walk in
and I I saw you and I literally cursed
at you you did your response was
priceless
I think I did mention a certain lady and
then an effort after it as well I did
say that I know but you were holding a
hat I thought it would be a tiger hat
and then you walk out here it says it's
a lot of state but no Lou Whitaker and
Trammell together that's that's that's
the combination from back in the day and
you know seeing Gibson out here as well
sometimes for for what the dodgers doing
that they're doing well what was it like
those 80s Tigers for you to go through
that after you said that the 68 World
Series was the last one yeah Wow I mean
it was it was crazy thirty-five and five
to start the year Morris throws that
no-hitter early on in his second start
maybe in April and and then and then the
rest of the year was just like okay then
with them we lost then we were thirty
five and six it was like oh can we hang
on you know I can't wait hang on a win
the pin and then I was actually on tour
I was living in New York and doing you
know theater and right I was on a
national tour of a Broadway musical and
that that big hit musical doonesbury
the musical after the cartoon after the
cartoon then Trudeau cartoon and and one
of my guy that I met in that tour Greg
Edelman a great Broadway actor singer
was born and raised in the Chicago area
and big Cubs fan and all during those
playoffs you know the Cubs against the
Padres he and I are thinking oh man it's
gonna be Cubs Tigers yeah it's gonna be
or the classic world series of all time
and then he's born then not yeah then it
was not you know so many people think
you know when you look back on it that
Tony Gwynn was on that that Padres team
but he was not yeah it was Garvey Rhys
Garvey leading that Padres team Steve
Garvey who a lot of people think should
be in Kent
first down as well but that those those
Padres were no joke going into that
series in the old right I think the
series itself was a kind of
anticlimactic five-game you know cleanup
Tigers Willie Hernandez and all those
guys yeah see because I showed up at
Michigan the next year in 86 and
everyone's talking about how great the
Tigers are and the Yankees were going
through that awful Steinbrenner period
where they were banishing people to the
Columbus Clippers as a threat yeah you
know by by Balboni Balboni for sure so
let's talk about father figures it is
hilarious and we had Bradshaw here a
couple weeks ago he must have been
awesome to be around on the set I did
not get to be around him on the set are
you serious no he didn't work - we
didn't work together I think he shot his
whole thing in Miami and I was shooting
in Atlanta but I did get to hang out
with him earlier this week actually met
for the first time doing some other
press things and he's just an awesome
guy we had a great time right and he's
really really good in the movie I mean
his whole his whole sequences there's
not a there's not a false beat in there
yes where he doesn't really mind playing
somewhat against type in a way yeah you
know yeah and when he was here we talked
about his his stent and smoking the
bandit - from that and he said a lot of
you know spent years in in acting school
since then yeah but to get to the point
where he's as good as he's and Terry
Bradshaw and father figures a funny
looking funny movie funny funny looking
movie all of it the commercials are
fantastic you see on Monday Night
Football counterpart on stars debuts
next January
this has a sort of Twilight Zone feel to
it would you would you agree with that
assessment
no sure yeah so describe what what
counterpart is and what what attracted
you to that role well it's it's the
Twilight Zone comparison works because
it's smart and it's mysterious and and
there's a little bit of a we hesitate to
use the word sy5 right kind of a
metaphysical you know
aspect to it at its heart it's a it's a
spy thriller really and I they send me
the script a few years ago when I was
kind of the flavor of the month and I
was getting a lot of offers and and I
actually fell in love with the character
and the script before we got to the big
reveal which audiences are all going to
know before you know it's not gonna
surprise anybody right that there's
actually two versions of this character
that I play although interestingly both
of them are bald how about that yeah cuz
you did you can't you put it in your
contract I was like one of them has like
this flowing mane yeah blonde Eric if
Brian Urlacher could suddenly have that
the lid on top right why can't JK say oh
they didn't they didn't go for it I'm
with you on that and that debut since on
Starz on January 21st of next year thank
you for coming in brother I really
appreciate that thank you for being here
and good luck against USC thank you
thank you and because you know I'm a Big
Ten guy well I am too honestly big tent
so Holderman
if Michigan was going against USC you'd
be rooting for Michigan absolutely I
root for Michigan every week of the year
except one okay yeah and then they are
not there then they're just that team up
north really no hold on a second
Michigan takes on Michigan State you
choose this side of Michigan yeah yeah
yeah because I want our butt-kicking to
be that much more painful I want you to
be undefeated and ranked number one okay
every year in the middle of November
because I kind of I'm kind of the
opposite you know I've got a 9 and a 6
and a 4 at home and the fact that my 9
year old looked at me the other day when
Michigan State played Ohio State it's
his dad who should we be rooting for who
should we be rooting again there's no
such thing as a tie right you know go to
19 overtime know what you used to be
able to root for that yes you know
that's true I missed actually do not
miss that ties I'm gonna slit eyes in
the in football I think football should
have tie games
now look last year I mean except on the
play between our schools when you didn't
get first down on fourth down okay that
was a great game
because it went into overtime for the
first time you didn't I mean you wanted
that game to end in a time well in this
in this era that's what you do but right
I think it would have been awesome to
have ended in a time that's that right
and by the way for one time during the
woody bow yeah the 10-year war I do have
to mention for the radio audience that
when I mentioned that you did not get
first on it fourth down you did throw
your head back and roll your eyes and
thank you because those on the radio
might think that you did not make any
sort of we have to gas such an
aggressive maneuver on my part certainly
since you're one of my favorite guests
ever not coming on thanks for coming in
here JK bud alright welcome back to the
Rich Eisen show I'm a glutton for
punishment and that's not the reason why
JK Simmons is still here okay so with
your ohio state hat and your ohio state
sweatshirt of boxers and your boxers
which i will just have to take your word
for show you later okay very good the
Academy award-winning actor JK Simmons
still here you're clutching a Rich Eisen
show card why well this was given to me
by your crack staff specifically Liz
from you're correct okay you this is a
problem because she's a huge Buckeye
person oh really yes okay so let's
wailed handed you to this card what is
what is on there well every year the
fandom 250 seeks to rank the best fan
bases in in the world and and this
covers it's very sports movies TV yeah
etc etc for example I just I only have
the top 10 in front of me not the top
250
ok number 9 is the Pittsburgh Steelers
probably like waving the towel they have
a lot of fans okay number seven is
Beyonce oh no it's very eclectic it's
yeah number number six is Netflix 5
Conor McGregor I'll just keep going
number 4 Star Wars
oh geez so it's very Star Wars beats out
Netflix which beats out Beyonce well
okay so your your your matriculating
your way up the up the chart here I'm
indeed number three Dwayne the rock
Johnson very
popular man absolutely have you ever
worked with the rock ah I have not
worked with the rock IIIi would love to
I still Larry yes I mean really hey I
think he's really really fun mm-hmm
let's not distract ourselves from the
mean I don't try my best with building
or building the tension number two Game
of Thrones oh wow I'm a big game of
Thrones fan and don't tell me number one
it's not why would I not number one do
you want to read it no I don't number
one is the Ohio State Buckeyes the
number one fan base these people in the
universe known to man 10 is Taylor Swift
eight is Alabama Crimson Tide
yeah let's that for a second number
eight
cause Alabama number one it's like what
is what is what is the metric of fandom
it clearly is clearly a scientifically
proven University has the best fan base
in the world we travel well I see endow
Game of Thrones the rock star Star Wars
Star Wars Star Wars is slightly below
the Star Wars which is gonna make you
read this list oh my god that is just oh
well I'm so glad you stuck around Jay
came oh me too
no but you know in all seriousness I
think Ohio State should be in a college
football playoff that is eight schools
large thank you we're we're still
Michigan Ohio State would have been for
a lot because a third Ohio State loss
pardon me third vo ah state loss it
would have knocked you out of that eight
oh absolutely knocked you out of the a
yes you can't get into an eight with
three losses essentially and that you
make teams five through eight visit the
teams that are one through four so Ohio
State still could be for naught because
you know and you don't have the danger
of having them play Clemson therefore
the horseshoes open for business for
Nick Saban
is it and that's a beautiful point too
because as a Big Ten guy you know every
time we're in a ball game it's a road
game and often for our opponent it's a
virtual home game I mean you don't have
bowl games in the big house or the shoot
well I'll tell you this right now
Wisconsin fans are hearing you right now
saying you bet
they're playing the Orange Bowl against
the Hurricanes yeah I mean it literally
is a Miami Hurricanes home game against
Wisconsin and when when the Big Ten
comes out here for the Rose Bowl you
know we're playing against you know
historically UCLA USC right somebody
who's just traveling down right and then
you know I think to like the 8c I would
have loved to see in Central Florida
take on Clemson even if their asses
beaten it would still would have me
tuning in I don't know I think UCF fans
have a legitimate grievance about the
play I mean who's the only undefeated
team and you know it's them see you look
at us agreeing on college football to
cute couple of Big Ten guys just whining
okay now get your ohio state underwear
out of this chair all right JK Simmons
again check out father figures and
theaters near you on December 22nd and
then counterpart on just January 21st on
stars good to see you sir for more Rich
Eisen show tuned to audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen
show app